Hi Drew, hi, Garcelle, I got married about 10 months ago,
and my husband and I, we have a five month old son.
I have two daughters from a previous relationship.
And my ex, he does a really great job helping with the kids.
We've come a really, really long way.
We even joke from time to time
that it feels like we're brother and sister.
So, my question is I wanna know
how I can get my ex and my husband to coexist
where it doesn't feel like we're in an awkward situation.
Is it cantankerous now?
Is it a little uneasy, awkward, tension?
It's not really tension.
It's just avoidance.
They kind of seem to just avoid each other.
Okay.
It's just very awkward.
They don't wanna co-exist.
Garcelle, what do you think?
Ooh, I think it's always awkward.
I think it's always awkward.
Last year I had, I was dating someone
and I decided for the first time
that I was going to bring my ex-husband,
who's always with us for Thanksgiving,
and the guy that I was dating,
and let me tell you, it was so awkward.
At one point, I went to the pantry
and took a shot at tequila (exhales),
and took a deep breath, and came back out.
I think the awkwardness is going to be there
until they do it more and more.
I think it's having a conversation
with each and each of them saying separately,
let's put the kids first, let's do the best we can.
I think once you address the elephant in the room,
that may help and your new husband is not going anywhere
and your ex isn't going anywhere.
So, I think it's beautiful
that they're willing to be in the same rooms.
So, talk it out with them
and say let's put the kids together.
And when you're talking to one, bring in the other one,
what do you think about this?
So that they feel that they can have a conversation.
But I get it, I get it, girl.
It is awkward, but it's okay.
It's all for the betterment of the kids.
I think give it time too, the more you force,
the more they'll resist.
And if you find yourself in this space in a while from now
and it just, you know in your gut and your heart
it's just been too long and it's just not going well,
at that point, readdress it, but for now,
just try to let it go and accept their approach,
reaction, behavior in this.
Yeah, do they have anything in common?
Do they like a certain sports team
or anything they can do, nothing?
They have you in common.
They're completely opposites.
They are different in a lot of ways.
So that's, I think the most thing
that will draw them together are the children.
And I really thank them too,
because even though they don't acknowledge
the coexisting situation, they put the kids first.
So, I'm really grateful for that.
Can I ask a question?
And by the way, this is so much harder
for me to practice than preach.
Just be you, do your thing.
Don't try so hard to sell it, your tension,
you might be the one bringing the tension,
just this is as good as it's gonna get right now.
And there are horror stories out there.
I'm sorry, but it's true.
So, if you're not living in one, that's a win.
Yes, yes, exactly, the fact that they're willing to be
in the same room together, in the same area together,
is huge, and the fact that they're putting the kids first,
you have a really good thing.
And I agree with Drew, give it time
and let them figure it out.
They're grown men, let them figure it out.
Thank you, ladies, I really appreciate that.
Thank you for sharing this
because I'm sure there's a lot of other people,
which is why I was excited to talk to Garcelle today
because a lot of us are in this boat,
and we're just trying to do the best we can,
and figure it out, and communicate,
and let each other know that you're not alone,
and here's some thoughts, and ideas, and approaches.
And so, thank you, Garcelle.
Thank you, Drew.
It's been so fun to do this with you.
You too, anytime.
All right, well, Garcelle Beauvais,
be sure to check out Garcelle's three-part book,
a series called "I Am",
and also check her out weekdays on "The Real",
check your local listings, just like our show.
(upbeat music)